[Música]
quizá haya cátedra marsans bienvenido a
radio canadá internacional
hola pablo muchas gracias
quizá ya vamos a hablar de ciclistas
solidarios explícanos por favor que
quiénes son que es de ciclistas
solidarios
bueno nosotros somos un grupo de
ciclistas que
de base nos gusta mucho hacer en la
bicicleta
y bueno con un corazón muy grande y con
la necesidad de ayudar a la gente
y el crear algo loco
y el grupo existe atrapado
bueno esto fue una organización muy
espontánea que empezó con la pandemia
cuando ahí vimos que hay necesidades y
que podemos ayudar a la gente
cómo
y la gente o sea la ayuda es ustedes
trabajan con organizaciones que
brindan el servicio de alimentación a
personas necesitadas
o sea son organizaciones o centros
sociales que ellos forman parte de la
seguridad alimentaria o sea que
van en cuenta de que la gente que no es
autónoma que puedan normalmente venir a
sus lugares y puedan buscar la comida o
cocinar juntos y cuando empezó la
pandemia ya no era posible de que esta
gente tenga el acceso a sus necesidades
básicas social a la alimentación
y es ahí donde ustedes los ciclistas
solidarios entran en acción claro ahí
nosotros nos dimos cuenta que podemos
ser el puente entre las organizaciones
sociales y la gente que ahora de golpe
se encuentra en casa ya no ya no tiene
el acceso y ahí empezamos toda una
logística increíble que desde hace sólo
dos meses funciona allí crece muy rápido
y tú me decías tú me decías y sabía que
son 800 ciclistas entonces para la
logística como tú me dice debe ser un
trabajo impresionante también
y nos da mucho trabajo pero estamos
afortunados porque al principio cuando
cuando allí pregunto sea hicimos la
llamada a muchos ciclistas cuando
preguntamos para que hagan las entregas
y que distribuyan también preguntamos si
hay algunos que quisieran hacer la
coordinación entonces ahora ya estamos
en un grupo de 23 personas que estamos
todos muy motivados
muy entusiasmados y claro nos
encontramos una vez la semana por su y
allí hacemos todo el check up todo
tenemos todos los números de la gente
hacemos llamadas tenemos una aplicación
ya e italia y quiénes son los ciclistas
voluntarios son gente se me imagino que
tiene que trabajar en otras cosas y es
un trabajo voluntario que hacen
bien estamos hablando de gente claro
voluntaria quién
sobre todo también por la pandemia no
tuvieron más trabajo
y entonces querían sentirse útiles
por eso estamos contentos también porque
para el grupo de coordinación nos hace
muchas cabezas distintas que tenemos
gente
que trabajen en varios en varias cosas
distintas entonces se nos suman las
ideas en logística o sea que gente
informáticos en coordinación que
mecánicos de bicicleta están bien
ciudadanos o sea si improvisamos y
funciona bien no no tenemos estructuras
hacemos como
como cada una con su idea
funcionaria y que que necesitas para
hacer ciclistas solidarios necesitas una
bicicleta o no necesitas bicicleta y la
organización que presta una como
funciones
necesitas un
una bicicleta eso sí pero también ahí
está
idea de los remolques
a poder cargar la comida entonces
tenemos afortunadamente algunos
ciclistas que ellos sí tienen remolques
pero nosotros también hemos podido
organizar como unas 20 de marcas que
vamos a ir distribuyendo a las ciclistas
para que podemos cargar lo más posible
en un día o en una
en 100 un delivery con una organización
de la gente en casa
cuántas entregas se hacen por ejemplo en
una semana y sharia
llegamos ya un buen número estamos a
7000 entre ellas por semana
tenemos 55 distritos con cuales estamos
trabajando y en estos cinco distritos
tenemos 18 organizaciones
por ejemplo ahora en la que tuvimos 48
miles entregas
que nos dijieron desde que empezamos
y en el mismo 200 entre ellas por día
tenemos desde el principio
bueno mucho trabajo y cuántos kilómetros
se pueden recorrer en una semana cuando
eres ciclista solidario
bueno buena pregunta
no sé si quiere decir los kilómetros
pero
lo que sí a veces hacemos como o sea un
grupo de dos personas que va a hacer una
entrega puede hacer como cinco hasta
cinco vueltas depende un poco también la
organización a veces son como cajitas de
comida más chiquitas más grandes
entonces dependiendo no también el cargo
que tenemos
se hacen más vueltas
pero lo que sí después la gente está
bastante cansada
pero en general como tenemos tanta
motivación y también hacemos un poco de
música así para qué hace el ambiente
bueno entonces estamos cansados después
a veces pero con mucha alegría con el
corazón muy contento me imagino que
quizá ya que van a continuar después de
la pandemia los ciclistas solidarios
ya esperando que la pandemia se termine
pronto
si nuestra idea es
queremos que el movimiento siga porque
nos importa mucho que la gente vea que
que la distribución de comida se pueda
hacer
en bicicleta y que no es necesario ver
siempre usar un coche o camiones para
hacerlo porque bueno somos el mejor
ejemplo de ver qué
que se puede entregar cantidades muy
grandes con bicicleta y ahora como ya
estamos muy muy bien organizados estamos
viendo que el sistema ya existe con los
con otras organizaciones de ciclistas
para poder trabajar allí en una
comunidad
y de despedirse esta en la que estamos
empezando y que me parece fantástica y
de hecho yo lo felicito porque es una
muy buen y sima acción y bueno pues la
gente
me imagino que debe estar muy contenta
cuando los ven llegar
hoy
está esclareciendo ver ya de un lado las
organizaciones
y les alegra mucho que les damos una
mano con eso porque normalmente la gente
venía a verles entonces no tenían no
tenían esa necesidad y no tenían ahí en
un organismo que haga las entregas
es ellos sí están muy felices y también
cuando vamos a entregar a la casa de la
gente obviamente siempre tomando todas
las medidas de seguridad yo el protocolo
sanitario me imagino
eso lo repetimos ser cada vez que vemos
la gente está muy importante sí bueno
ella es la gente en sus casas están muy
felices muy agradecidos que les vemos
hay una mano
para que les facilitamos el acceso a
estas ayudas sociales
los ciclistas obviamente porque les
encanta andar en bicicleta porque se
sienten los útiles y pueden ayudar de
verdad si es una muy buena sima acción
ya para terminar ahí está ya yo hoy que
la alcaldesa de montreal valeri plante
quiere abrir más cerrar algunas calles y
abrir más pistas ciclables eso para los
ciclistas solidarios me imagino que es
una una buena iniciativa
y estuvimos muy felices cuando
escuchamos esto creo que estamos
hablando ya de
120.000 km2 en mil kilómetros y que
también la posibilidad que que se quede
así no y justo es ahí vemos nosotros el
momento importante de de lanzar el
mensaje que se pueda hacer mucho más en
bicicleta y también de de que se pueda
bajar la contaminación allí a la vez
podemos subir la solidaridad
esperemos que
que sigan las calles esperando y creo
que ahí con los ciclistas podemos dar un
muy buen mensaje y demostrar que
realmente funciona que podemos dar
facilitar a la gente que tengan el
acceso para las ayudas sociales y
esperadas para los coches tenemos menos
tráfico estamos súper felices
muy bien muy bien quizá ya muchísimas
gracias por esta entrevista a radio
canadá internacional
muchas gracias a ti pablo fue un placer
y ahí espero de poder motivar a más
gente que usan la bicicleta
en verano y en invierno que ahí sí la si
la infraestructuras y así podemos
hacerlo con mucho más placer
[Música]